[Musique]
oui pour en parler nous sommes avec
gérard longuet sénateur l es12 la meuse
bonsoir gérard longuet merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés jean christophe lagarde
président hu dei député de la 5e
circonscription de seine-saint-denis
bonsoir jean christophe lagarde merci
d'être avec nous alors pour calmer le
jeu on la vit emmanuel macron a donc
déjeuner avec gérard larcher président
du sénat et les chefs de groupes
parlementaires du sénat pour déminer
donc cette politique autour de l'article
24 les députés auraient dû être associer
davantage même si comme l'a rappelé hier
gérard larcher tête au sénat évidemment
de réécrire le texte
jean christophe lagarde écoutez on
confine au ridicule hier monsieur à tan
porte-parole du gouvernement disait dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale qu'
il reprend me reprocher aux oppositions
de ne pas avoir fait cette proposition
on lui a fait des propositions mais
comme d'habitude arrogant et sûr de même
le gouvernement et la majorité ont dit
finalement que il avait raison et que
quoi qu'il arrive il adopté le texte tel
qu'il l'avait prévu
pire que ça une fois avoir adopté le
texte et se rendre compte qu'ils avaient
voté un texte qui non seulement
n'interdisait pas aux journalistes de
filmer ou aux citoyens de filmer et
diffuser mais le protéger en rien aux
policiers ils ont décidé de le réécrire
et ils ont juste oublié une petite chose
c'est que le sénat existait c'est à dire
que c'est aujourd'hui le sénat qui a le
texte entre les mains dans le dos
navette parlementaire et ils disent on
va réécrire le texte qu'ils attendent
déjà que le sénat travaille je leur ai
dit moi même dans l'hémicycle que ce
texte serait réécrit par de sénart parce
que c'était une évidence parce qu'il
était ni efficace ni utile qu'en réalité
ils percevaient il ne permettait de
poursuivre absolument rien donc résultat
des courses c'est entre les mains du
sénat et on nous a sortis avant d une
commission une commission c'est à dire
des gens qui ne sont élus par personne
qui me rendent de comptes à personne
pour réécrire la loi
on est arrivés dans un tel pataquès
qu'il faut revenir à la sagesse le sénat
est normalement une chambre où les
passions sont moins grandes où les
enjeux politiques semblent moins grand
mais par contre tous les enjeux à la
fois d' équilibre de
loi et de libertés individuelles sont
plus respectés malheureusement qu'à
l'assemblée nationale alors précisément
la commission indépendante à laquelle
vous faites allusion aux mises en place
par le premier ministre rage aussi des
propositions sur les relations entre la
presse et les forces de sécurité tandis
que la commission des lois de
l'assemblée va réécrire d'ici quinze
jours ce fameux article 24 de la
proposition de loi sécurité ça vous
convient
gérard larcher qu'attendez-vous de cette
commission et simplement
mais non ça ne convient pas du tout je
pense que le président de la république
mais connaît profondément le
fonctionnement de nos institutions
parlementaires
la france est un état de droit président
de la république un rôle éminent
principal mais ce n'est pas lui
et ce n'est pas son gouvernement qui
votent la loi ce sont les parlementaires
nous à les députés en dernier ressort et
les sénateurs sont actuellement
consultées et en général faut savoir que
dans notre pays
60 à 70% des amendements proposés par le
sénat sont en général retenu par
l'assemblée nationale
donc nous ont vraiment notre rôle de
modérateur et nous avons bien
l'intention de le jouer complètement et
nous n'accepterons pas ce sentiment
d'être guidé d'être encadrés par une
commission extérieure une commission
théodule qui n'aura d'autre légitimité
que d'avoir été nommé par hans et qui
d'ailleurs parce que entre le président
de la république et le premier ministre
on ne sait pas très bien qui a eu cette
idée lumineuse
après que l'assemblée nationale se soit
exprimée de dire 90 café l'assemblée
nationale ne compte pas et on va
réécrire nous-mêmes ce texte c'est une
tragédie française parce que nous avons
besoin en période de crise d'avoir des
institutions qu'ils soient respectés
avec la contribution de chacun il ya des
gens de droite des gens de gauche il ya
toutes sortes d'opinions toutes sortes
d'expériences
c'est aux institutions de fonctionner ce
n'est pas au président de la république
et son entourage immédiat de décider ce
que veulent les français les français
routes et des élus des parlementaires
pour cela que le président les laisse
travailler dans leurs fonctions alors
des sénateurs de gauche eux aussi sont
émus de cet épisode de navettes
parlementaires qui ne grandit pas notre
démocratie selon eux je vous propose de
regarder avant de réagir le tweet du
patron des sénateurs ps patrick kader le
gouvernement est en train de perdre son
sang froid
il n'y aura plus de commission pourrait
écrire l'article 24
ce sont les groupes majoritaires qui ont
décidé de le réécrire
alors que nous sommes en pleine navette
parlementaire c'est un peu le grand
n'importe quoi sur le plan
institutionnel
c'est totalement contraire aux textes
qui régissent notre démocratie qui est
un faux patrick anr et d'un prochain de
françois hollande qui a lui-même invité
emmanuel macron à retirer ce texte il
faut retirer ce projet de loi de ces
curieuses retirer l'article 24 selon
vous jean christophe lagarde
ni l'un ni l'autre on a aujourd'hui un
problème
les forces de sécurité les forces de
l'ordre sont régulièrement film et est
diffusée sur les réseaux sociaux
ce qui en soi est normal puisque ça
permet de savoir ce qu'il s'est passé le
problème c'est que les policiers les
gendarmes
nos fonctionnaires qui garantissent
notre sécurité sont identifiés et
attaqués dans leur vie privée lorsque
ceux ci se produit il ya donc une
solution
pardon déquilibre simple que vue d y a
proposé c'est qu'on doit consacrer le
droit de diffuser deux films et une
opération de police mais que pour autant
on ne doit pas pouvoir reconnaître les
personnes qui sont dans l'action
pourquoi je dis ça parce que vous et moi
on a besoin de savoir ce qui s'est passé
pas qui a fait quoi
et ce sont les magistrats les
inspections de la gendarmerie les
inspections de la police nationale qui
ont besoin de savoir qui donc c'est très
simple en réalité pour faire en sorte
que les médias ou les citoyens puissent
permettre de faire connaître ce qui
s'est passé notamment quand ça s'est mal
passé parce que c'est là où ces fusées
de savoir ce qui s'est passé sans qu'on
sache l'identité des personnes
l'idée dans l'identité des personnes
elle concerne les inspections générales
elle concerne les juges sans magistrats
ceux qui sont amenés à sanctionner mais
on n'en est plus là on n'en est plus là
l'absurdité de la décision
gouvernementale
et comme le disait gérard longuet de ce
non respect des institutions où on nous
invente des gens qui ne sont pas
parlementaires
cette fameuse commission qui ne rendent
de comptes devant personnes qui n'ont de
légitimité devant personne qui ferait la
loi à la place de ceux qui sont élus
pour ça jeudi une sauce un pardon mais
ce n'est pas la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale qui va réécrire le
texte de loi c-2 sénat qu'il a
aujourd'hui entre les mains de moi je
fais confiance au sénat pour trouver un
équilibre sur l'article et sur l'article
22 qui lui est gravement attentatoire
aux libertés publiques
on y reviendra j'espère parce que
l'article 24 n'empêchait pas ni les
citoyens ni journalistes de filmer de
diffuser mais ne protégeait pas de
policiers il faut le réécrire et le
sénat doit le faire puisque l'assemblée
la majorité de playmobil qui ont levé la
main sur un texte
ils sont prêts à faire la même chose au
contraire dans quelques semaines le
sénat doit faire son boulot avec sagesse
et il doit regarder l'article 22 parce
que cet article 22
il est dangereux réellement dangereux
parce qu'aujourd'hui en l'état tel qu'il
a été voté par l'assemblée nationale et
je lui dis dans les débats de
l'assemblée nationale il permet à
n'importe quel policier avec des drones
de surveiller en tout temps et en tout
lieu
tous les citoyens en dehors de leur
domicile ce sans aucun contrôle d'un
magistrat
gc pardonnez-moi jean christophe lagarde
assez intéressant ce que vous nous dites
justement parce que beaucoup craignent
ou dix en tout cas que le sénat
majoritairement à droite on le rappelle
comptent durcir ce texte avec
précisément
tic 22 auquel vous faites allusion
l'utilisation des drones est ce qu'on
bascule dans un état de plus en plus
autoritaire aux gérard longuet non alors
le sénat est très attentif à la ce
qu'ils sont de la démocratie c'est à
dire le principe de liberté individuelle
nous acceptons naturellement la
discipline de la sécurité le respect de
la loi le respect de l'autorité
mais nous entendons profondément que les
pouvoirs publics n'utilisent pas leur
autorité pour viol et d'une façon
constante et sans contrôle
évidemment la liberté de chacun cette
affaire de drogue et est exemplaire de
du travail bâclé dans la préparation des
textes et comme l'a dit jean christophe
lagarde de l'incapacité de ceux qui sont
au banc du gouvernement à l'assemblée ou
au sénat
le comprendre que certaines choses
doivent être révisées yahia aucun
déshonneur
à quand on est ministre allait
finalement vous avez raison cet aspect
je l'avais mal vu mes collaborateurs
était trop orienté professionnel pas
assez liberté quand on a un savoir faire
politique eh bien on évalue et on tire
les conséquences d'une éventuelle bévue
or cette affaire de drones est en effet
une début parce que au moment où on
découvre que nous sommes fichus fliquer
par par les grands réseaux sociaux qui
exploite toutes les données et il ya une
réaction européenne qui est assez saine
il
il ya des mesures comme les rg en
france ferries en europe qui s'efforce
de protéger les libertés
il faudrait que ce soit nos
fonctionnaires qui chacun proprio me tue
décide d'utiliser un drone dans savoir
ce qui se passe dans votre jardin
si vous êtes avec votre conjoint avec
votre voisine par exemple si vous faites
la fête ou si au contraire vous bricoler
absolument invraisemblable
alors je pense que évidemment c'est une
vision excessive mais à l'origine c'est
le manque de dialogue
le manque d'approfondissement on veut
vick on n'écoute personne et on bâcle
des textes et on arrive évidemment à des
déroutes législatives parce que la
france a quand même une tradition
juridique solide des et des magistrats
magistrat public leur judiciaires qui
sont capables de notre point de vue et
j'ajoute parce que les commissions dont
on parle d'experts c'est avant la loi
qui me faut les écouter
il n'y a rien de déshonorant pour un
ministre a convoqué des bâtonniers les
avocats des magistrats il les écoute
avant mais quand le texte est présenté
devant le parlement
alors c'est au parlement de faire son
travail et s'il ya eu des erreurs y
compris l'article 22 mai c'est pas le
seul eh bien il faut avoir la
l'honnêteté de dire qu'on s'est trompé
quand le mal qu mal évaluer une
situation en tout cas oui le débat est
désormais lancée on l'a on l'a entendu
hier avec vous d'ailleurs jean
christophe lagarde
alors j'ai je n'ai pas fini parce qu'on
entendait jean christophe lagarde à
l'assemblée hier lancé au style le débat
alors parmi les pistes en au sujet de ce
fameux article 24 toujours gens m'ont un
jean castex l'annoncé ce matin
l'appliquent 25 du projet de loi dont
l'objectif selon premier miss n'est pas
éloigné de l'article 24 pourrait être
une piste d'aboutissement
ça vous conviendrait jean christophe
lagarde beaucoup d'émoi je ne prononce
jamais avoir d'avoir un texte sur les
yeux parce que vous savez quand on vote
la loi ce qui ma responsabilité ce qui
est celle de gérard longuet de
l'assemblée du sénat
il faut regarder le texte pourquoi parce
qu'après des magistrats vont avoir à
l'interpréter et à l'appliquer et donc
la virgule elle est important dans un
texte de loi
or pardon quand on nous parle d'
intentions après ce que je viens de voir
de subir comme nous l'avons tous subi
sur l'article 24
il faut arrêter de faire des plex
d'amateurs vous savez le président de la
république disait il ya un an je crois à
ses députés
soyez fiers d'être des amateurs moi je
dis au président de la république et
limitent à natori
c'est à dire que quand on fait la loi et
encore plus la loi pénale c'est qu'il
nous sanctionne quand nous faisons des
fautes on doit être sérieux et comme
vient de le dire gérard longuet
il faut que ce gouvernement que ce
pouvoir accès apprennent la vertu de l'
échange du débat du dialogue parce que
moi je ne prétends pas avoir toujours
raison et parfois dans le débat
j'entends des gens qui disent des choses
intelligentes auquel je n'avais pas
pensé et qui peut même qui me permettre
de changer mon opinion qu'est ce qui
s'est passé sur l'article de 24 comme
sur l'article 22 et des drones c'est pas
les drones qui sont en cause c'est
simplement cette espèce d'idée
permanente d'avoir toujours raison de ne
jamais se tromper
et bien moi je lance un avertissement
tous les pouvoirs qui ont cru faire ça
de droite comme de gauche
et aujourd'hui le pouvoir mac rognant se
sont enfermés dans leurs certitudes et
se sont effondrés devant les électeurs
parce que les français ne sont pas
idiots ils savent bien quant à pouvoir
se bourhis bourg et ils savent le
sanctionner on a besoin dans notre pays
de débats et d équilibre de confiance
dans l'équipe des institutions la
lumière ne vient pas de l'elysée et
l'obscurité n'est pas au sénat ou à
l'assemblée nationale d'ailleurs à
l'assemblée nationale ils feraient bien
de laisser leurs députés réfléchir se
libérer voter est pas être son du canon
en fonction de ce qui a été décidé par
les uns et par les autres
l'article 24 n'était pas liberticide
mais il doit être réécrite parce qu'il
était inefficace
l'article 22 est clairement liberticide
et il doit être réécrit par le sénat et
par l'assemblée nationale pour qu'on
permette l' usage des drones mais que ça
ne se passe pas dans n'importe quelle
condition
parce que comme le dit gérard longuet ça
peut se faire n'importe quelle émotion
mais c'est même pire que ce qu'il disait
avec un drone on peut savoir dans votre
bureau ce que vous êtes en train de lire
on peut regarder ce que vous êtes en
train d'échanger puisqu'avec la lecture
labiale on peut savoir ce que vous étiez
en train de dire on peut regarder ce que
vous faites dans votre salle de sport
dans l'autre véhicule dans votre jardin
non mais attendez il ya qu'en chine que
ça ne choquerait personne mais pas dans
la république française
gérard longuet le modèle français l'insu
de la gauche veut le retrait du texte la
droite veut
réécrire l'article c'est pas un piège
dans lequel finalement est tombée
emmanuel macron cette fois de sécurité
notamment cet article 24 ce sera le mot
de la fin pour vous manque de
professionnalisme et travail solitaire
voilà c'était une conclusion
effectivement rapide merci à vous gérard
longuet merci également à vous jean
christophe lagarde président et des
députés de la 5ème circonscription de
seine-saint-denis gérard longuet
sénateur et l'air de la meuse merci à
tous les deux